it literally is a propane tank sized
thermos of water yes if water is water
in there what's in there for real this
is water and it stays cold and I love my
new water box you don't need to be that
[ __ ] hydrated bro I've always been
hydrated I was before the curve back in
high school I used to take a ragged
ginger ale bottle down
filled with water my old man used to
like ginger ale and club soda before I
got trendy you started drinking water
carrying the water job I'm always
drinking way too much my shower what do
they say in LA [ __ ] love avocado
toast lavender ice cream okay water jug
started the trend yeah I absolutely did
you can go ragged you remember used to I
used to dress probably like you guys did
like a pickup basketball game was about
to break out I used to have like bull
shorts and like a horrible free t-shirt
and then you'd have like the the 2-liter
bottle was all just skid marks and dirt
and it was just sitting underneath the
post and and then and that's and now
today we got a thing that looks like a
propane tank because you had a family of
nine you could go for three weeks this
would be enough propane 100% I can get
halfway across the Sahara with just that
right yes that's my bass is just la tap
water as a matter of fact bro no my good
friend Dylan Stewart with whom I grew up
in back home sure he lives out here no
you know him he lives in Long Beach he's
a little bit of a conspiracy theorist
and he went through it did his own
testing on the LA water system and the
tap water he says it's much better than
it was even five years ago scientist or
I mean so my friends Maura my friends
Maura is a structural or engineer civil
civil engineer who deals with just water
yeah and she's a scientist as a PhD and
she was explaining that the water supply
as it comes through taps and yeah all
the stringent standards is a lot of
times way cleaner than you get from
bottled exactly what his friend found
you guys
so myself don't be jealous when you hear
how refreshing I sound a piss me off dr.
Dodd read math me too
we didn't do a commercial man we're
still a commercial yeah we want to do a
commercial and we thought maybe you
could pipe in you got it because the
thing is like you know I look super
young right right
you know how you know how I have
boundless energy is energy because I
it's like Brian you tap into the source
and in a way it's not magic it's not
matter like you're the one saying all
this stuff no you know you're heavily
influencing what other people's think or
at least you're trying to know by
constantly saying it I don't know but
people always say would you say that's
the rumor yeah but you're the room also
when you say people always say 9s people
never say whatever you know but I'm
saying in the sporting circles okay and
in the artistic circles where energy
right and charisma and linear symmetry
circles meeting where you and your wife
play tennis and the artistic circles
where you and your children do crafts at
home look bro that's not just no I'm
talking about in the Avon guy in the a
long gown so I'll say it like sing in
album gal circles of you know say the D
yeah friends
well because yeah and the people go
Brian you have boundless energy speaking
of speaking of songs I like to sing a
song when I come here right one is the
man and the other is the father and the
other is the other guy
[Applause]
fighter in the kid is brought to you by
ten minute podcast it's will sasso spod
cast ha and Bryan used to be on it also
brought to you by clam chowder the
health food that nature intended
everybody but yeah after after you left
the the smell in the room returned to
just the the gas from my [ __ ] and uh
just to keep it up yeah I actually
farted into the mic for you yes you
weren't there well I remember one time
when I had our new house it was our new
house where my family was was and my
wife my my newborn newborn and and I had
my sweet little daughter with maybe
three and you you came over for a little
bit you you ate all the cheese in my
fridge yeah I was eating it out of a bag
you ate all the cheese and then you and
then you said well I'll see you guys
later now in my house and Brendan you
don't remember this that um that you
ever went there I had a downstairs
bathroom with a glass door just a glass
door so there wasn't a lot of you knows
a glass door and we were seeing him to
the door and he said I'm gonna make a
left turn here I'm gonna go to the
bathroom give me a second he made a left
her and he closed that glass door and he
shat into that bowl and it made such a
loud noise and my wife went my way went
oh my god I go oh yeah she goes but it's
our new house I go well he's taking this
shot in our new house and he got up and
he goes to see you later and with his
big meatballs grab my wife gave her a
big old smooch awesome though you know
even might have he washed his hands
where he didn't I don't know but the
bottom line is there was some there was
some poo poo germs on his hands yeah
grabbed her by the couple cheeks gave
her a big hug about his face uh-huh
inappropriate kiss she was she felt
traumatized and then smacked me on the
ass and left how about the time that me
and our good pal Marshall cook went over
there while you were out of town and
Marshall took his shirt off and we took
a bunch of pictures with him holding
bottles of wine he took a picture of me
he had he said he had both my children
in his hands with a dead face
yep and it was a picture and said I'm at
your home dead eyes with Stella and
Fenimore and Marshall has a good body's
young and he took all these pictures we
showed up with my wife in his arms not
it's not appropriate when I want to soar
when I sprout my eagle wings and I want
to soar yeah there's a limit yes so
whatever you gonna plan to go what's
your what's your load if there's an
extra bag yeah and we got a friend of
the show friend and this is on believe
know sure the others watching
no no lounges left us in my life oh no
leftists see I knew your vote for Trump
every one within the sound of my voice
we're gonna close out this episode with
Brian's word for Donald Trump you know I
appreciate that everyone's continued to
listen to Tim in a podcast we're gonna
move on with the fighter and the kid
here it's always a joy to come by and I
want loyal listeners of 10-minute
podcasts to appreciate the show to know
that the reason that Brian hasn't been
by is because Brian is gonna vote for
Donald Trump not and and because Chris
won't vote at all no idea and I'm so I'm
very political and I'm running as a
third party nominee and I'd like to make
my announcement now thank you so much
for listening please vote for me in 2016
with my running mate Chad coffee
Oh unbeliever I'm cutting the fat and
that was 10 minutes we actually didn't
think you would you got Evan the beard
the cub that's the lose Ryan it's not an
Oldsmobile just buy a new one hey you
don't have to worry about your trading
what do I get our trade-in I know I have
expensive right Brian you don't have
$700 Lana you got to be mean whatever
take me for a $700 lunch
right now yeah I wanted don't want to
say this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]